county officials are close to wrapping  up the vote count from election day  registrar of voters joe gloria says 1200  ballots were processed on monday  and just some outstanding ballots remain  glorious as his staff are making good  progress on provisional records and they  should finish by thursday  in the face of voter fraud allegations  gloria remains confident in providing  the correct results  we tried very hard as a department to  make sure that we're  providing information that answers the  questions that the general public has  so we're very very confident that  everything that we put through  will be qualified voters members of the  trump campaign are disputing some of the  results from the election and how it's  being handled  today is the final day for mail-in  ballots to go to the clark county  election department